hello everyone and welcome today's
webinar
improved quantitative understanding of
oncological replication kinetics using
molecular combing
i'm mark lynch of genomic vision and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by genomic vision
to learn more visit genomicvision.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
and you may submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation i'd like to
now welcome our speaker
marie averlo product manager at genomic
vision
mario you may now begin your
presentation
hi mark thank you so much for the kind
introduction
welcome everybody to the third
seminar today and uh i'm gonna discuss
about the improved quantitative
understanding
of oncological replication of kinetics
using
our molecular combing technology
this is the third part of our summer
webinar program
uh where actually in the first part you
learn
uh about molecular coming in general and
how are the applications
that can be used with it so in the
second part we
actually learn how to use molecular
combing
with our unique genomic morse codes
the to make a molecular marker to see
large genomic rearrangements um
and today we're actually going to go
through the use of molecular coming
to understand the replication
kinetics and the mechanism of
replication kinetics
in cancer biology so the difference
of it in normal cells and in cancer
cells
and how this can be used with uh protein
modification
or drug screening and
in the next uh seminar on
july 1st you actually will learn
what is the use of molecular combing in
gene editing
to qualify and quantify the genomic
rearrangements happening after gene
editing
after the use of crispr cast 9 for
example
or doing biomanufacturing for therapies
so today as mentioned we will focus
mostly on oncology
and will focus to understand
how the replication of kinetics are
in cancer cells how to compare
replication kinetics
between normal and cancer cells by using
our unique replication combing assay
so this is indeed used to see accurate
measurements of dna replication of
kinetics
to see the replication effect of
arrangements
in target genes and this will actually
bring
to the drug developments by the
identification of the replication stress
events and drug screening and efficiency
at the very end
so indeed the agenda of today is
actually divided in two parts
the first part is gonna be based
on the principle of our replication
coming assay
in our molecular combing technology
and the second part is to actually walk
you through
or what is the use of our rca
and single dna molecule technology for
drug
discoveries screening and then at the
end for
treatment refining so but now
let's start immediately and go to the
principle
or that are leading uh the
rca in single dna molecule resolution
so as everybody knows uh there are
different phases
in the circle life of a cells they're
going from
uh the g1 to the duplication
of the genome that then it goes to
mitosis so
for dividing these into the two daughter
cells
with molecular combing we actually will
focus on the dna replication itself
so basically we will see
what are the replication events that are
occurring during the s phase of our cell
and this is actually how our replication
coming yeah say
look like in this coverslip you can see
here
in blue the single strand dna fibers
and in red and green the replication
trucks
i highlighted with the wider arrows the
origins of replication as well so
basically you can
already see what is the power of the
technology
because we can actually detect the
bubbles so
the bidirectional fork already in a
single
dna molecule resolution and this is a
very
powerful resolution for our replication
coming assay
but now how to work with it what are the
different steps
that are walking you through the
uh the use of the replication coming
assay
in combination with molecular combing
so in the step one there is the pulse
labeling
so the path leveling is indeed to
pulse cells with two different timidine
analogues that are here cldu
and ibu so these are modified
uh analogues the ntps
uh to in order to have a chlorum or a
yodium
on top that can be used for the
visualization later on
so basically we have in this schema here
three origins of replication the three
gray circle and we know that especially
in human cells the replication is
asynchronous
so not all replication of fire at the
same time
so basically we will pulse for 30
minutes with the first nucleotide
in this case it's cldu in red
so what we will see is actually that
the replication has been fired already
on the first bubble uh one
in the time we use the red so while
it's exactly at the same time when we
use the red in the second bubble
and the third bubble hasn't been fired
yet
so then we wash out the cldu
and we use the second pulse that's idu
in this case
for more 30 minutes and we'll see in
green
so then we can see the continuous of the
tracks
from the replication forks in the first
bubble
in the second one and then in this case
we'll see
also the third bubble that will be fully
green
so in this case
we go to what is actually the
replication
tracks in a combing indeed we use a
counter staining
to visualize the single strand dna in
blue
and then in red and green the
replication tracks
and this brings to identification of the
timing
of which an origin has been fired
at that specific time of
one hour or 60 minutes for the two
different pulses
so then by using our replication combing
assay we can actually
then take measurements of each single
track
in order to have a precise statistical
analysis
so the replication coming essay or
say is a powerful technology that will
actually bring more detail that the
normal used uh technology in the lab
uh so indeed rca allows
to have seven different kinds of
signals according uh the
actual uh bubble firing so in the timing
that previously i show
and this will have the initiation one
so where we have the blue
uh in the middle then the two red
trucks the two green trucks and
the two blue extremities so
this is actually our replica where we
can
clearly distinguish uh one replication
forks on the right
and the other replication forks on the
left
then the initiation two well we actually
see
that there are the the green trucks
and the red trucks and the blue at the
end
in this case the replicon is the second
origins that the previously shown
so it started exactly at the same time
with that
when we use the cldu the red one
so for this uh case you don't see the
blue
in the middle of the red but we can
still
see the two forks on the red and on the
right
on the left and on the right and then
later on we can also see the initiation
three
so this is the latest that has been
fired because
con it contained only the
green trucks so only the second pass
and not the first one so these are three
different kind of initiations but
with combing we can also see termination
indeed
termination is shown as a flipped caller
compared to the inefficiency because we
consider that the bubble is going to
fuse together
when the replication goes at the end for
this case we have the termination one
where we actually see only red trucks
and in this case we consider that the
green truck
has been fused together so in the uh
replication
has been resolved for the first uh
for the second pulse so now we only see
the first one there is like the red
then we have the termination two in this
case we have the green truck
in the middle and the red are the
extremities
and then the blue extremities so these
actually
bring us to see that the replication
the green are actually going to fuse
together and after the
the red is coming and then we have the
latest
that has been fired again in time of
replication firing
so well it's called termination 3 where
we still see
a blue in between so these the green
are going to this will take some time to
fuse together
and finally we can see the
unidirectional fork the unidirectional
fork
are basically those fork that are that
went
so apart each other from the other fork
on the other side
that is considered at this time
unidirectional
so the other part the other strong part
of our rca
is actually that we can see always the
blue
or the single strand dna at the
extremities
of the replicons and these actually
bring us to avoid
any bias of dna breakage
into the analysis by using our molecular
combine technology
so by rca we have
seven different kinds of signals we
avoid
to have a bias coming from
the dna breaks that might be introduced
by the stretching forces
that are applied to the dna itself
because
we only take for statistical analysis
the intact signals so this case
we can actually use the parameters
different parameters to understand the
mechanistic role of the replication
kinetics
so we can basically see at the fork
speed
so in this case we have a fork speed of
unidirectional or
inexcision one in the picture below
what we actually do is understanding
uh or calculating the speed of the two
trucks
so the green and the red or the
green and red for both forks so on the
left and on the right
and then we can see if there is a
shorter replication going on
on a specific dna fiber like the one
that
show in the picture below where we can
see
that the two green are actually smaller
than the two reds in this case
then we can also see fork symmetry
so basically whether the symmetry of the
right fork
it's the same of the left fork or
vice versa so in this case we can see
two different pictures again in one you
can clearly see
that the fork on the right is definitely
smaller
it's a symmetrical respect to the fork
on the left
well in the second picture we actually
have two replicants
so we have four different forks
and you can see that uh the the replicon
on the left there are the two
uh green trucks so two forks
that actually are proceeding slower
because the fork speed of the green
truck
is actually smaller but the replicant is
still symmetrical
but if you look on the right side the
other two folks
you can see that the fork on the right
is actually going slower because the
green
is smaller than the red but on the fork
on the left side
the green is not there anymore so in
that case we consider that this is a
fork stalling
so the fork has sold exactly at that
point when we use
the second pulse that is actually the
green
then we can also see replicating dna so
we can take the amount of dna fibers or
single strand dna fibers
that are on the cover sleep and we can
also calculate
the amounts in number kb
of the replicating dna that are
all over the coverslip and with this we
can give a statistical analysis so what
is the replicating dna of oracle
sleep just to give you an idea on
average
uh for a replication coming assay
we use 10 000 cells at the beginning
in a flag and from these 10 000 cells
each coverslip will have something about
3 000 signals from forks
so this gives us a large number to play
and work with in order to have the
replicating dna
and finally we can also give the
inter-origin
or indetermination distance so these are
distance
for example between two different
equations so between
two different origins or between two
different terminations
and they're very useful to understand
for example the efficiency of a drug
because if we consider that we go
in a fork slow down or even stalling we
what the cells does normally is
actually fire at normal origin
so in that case the interraging distance
becomes shorter
so you can already see from these
few parameters and this few picture that
i gave you what is the strength
of our molecular combine technology used
with the rca with the replication
combing assay
indeed we can go with long fibers so we
have up to three megabases
if we compare for example with the used
technology that is called
fiber spreading and has been used in the
lab since
uh the latest 70s
and but the comparison between the two
technologies
brings a clearly advanced to the use of
genomic vision
technology itself so the molecular
combing
together with the rca so we have an
indeed a cost instruction factor
and this brings us uh to have parallel
fibers
that can be visualized uh in uh
single-strand dna and with the four
trucks
on it so this will bring to complexity
of signals
having seven different classification uh
rca will then allow to have many
parameters as
fork speed speeds spoke symmetry in
number of
origins replicating dna interorigins and
determination distance
we can distinguish between intact not
intact signals in order to avoid
any bias coming from the molecular
combing itself
and again we have uh
also for the replication combing assay a
specific module for
our fiber studio software in order to
have standardized analysis
and to perform the rca our
equipment and our consumables are very
crucial to be successful
in the performance of the replication
convenience say
indeed you want to use our fiber prep
kits for the dna extraction
it's a peculiar extraction kit that we
use
uh plug so the the sauce will be
embedded into the plug
and in order to preserve the integrity
of the dna molecule itself
then the dna will become on our cover
sleeves that are chemically treated
in order to allow to bind the surface
only
at the end of the dna itself
and then our fibre comb machine will
actually
apply the force to stretch physically
the dna molecule on the coverslip in
order to have
parallel long fibers in a native form
and then we use our fiber vision
s it's a an automated scanner that will
take
25 by 25 picture and stitch it together
in order to digitalize the physical
cover sleep in a digital version where
all the signals
are detected for the replication itself
and finally as mentioned before we have
our fiber studio analysis
software to actually detect
and help you into performing the
analysis for
uh our replication combing assay
so we are at the end of this first part
of the seminar
so and we spoke about the molecular
combing there is a unique tool to
understand the replication kinetics
we actually saw what is the efficiency
of replication that can be understood
by using our rca and what are all the
different parameters
that will give a deep
understanding of the mechanistic events
that are happening
on the replication itself so that will
bring
an understanding of the replication
kinetics and a comparison between
different kind of cells for example
normal and cancer cells
and then the parameters that are
detected and ionized
by our fiber studio software in order to
help
in your analysis and make make it
more standard
by this we move to the second chapter to
the second part of this seminar where we
actually will focus more on the
applications of our rca
into the drug discoveries drug screening
and at the end this can be used for
refining
our treatments
as everybody knows in
since years the different kind of
biomarkers or proteins has been used
and has been targeted in order to
develop uh
drugs that are anti-cancer drugs these
actually fall
in many pathways of the of the
cell itself for the dna replication
and repair system so that can be the
homologous recombination then
non-homologous enjoying
and some other pathways for example the
most known
nowadays is part one but there are many
others as
paul theta or bracawan gene that
actually has been used so all these
biomarkers
involve the use of replication machinery
and thus they affect can be efficiently
quantified by the use of replication
coming assay
indeed if we work at the principle of
rca
in drug discoveries we have neoplastic
cells that have a sovereign numerator of
origins of replication
that brings to have a more
replicants and replication fork so
depending what is the kind of treatment
against what kind of biomarker what is
happening that you can impede the origin
or replication itself
that will bring to less replicants or
you will like to work on the fork itself
so all of these can be seen and
visualized
and analyzed by our replication
combination
and our fiber studio software will
actually
help you to standardize all these
analyses
in a way that the software itself can
detect
all the replication folks and give
already
whether these are in session one two and
three or termination
123 or unidirectional and the user has
approved or discard
the signals and at the end the
report will be generated as you can see
in the 0.3
with all the quantification of the drug
efficiency
for for example the fork speed on the
inter-origin distance
when is in combination with a protein
mutation
and a drug using in this case
uh you can see for example the blue
versus the red one
and also for the inter-origin distance
so
by this you can actually screen
and quantify what is uh the efficiency
of a specific treatment
or a protein modification or combined
together
but then how to look uh and how to
design an experiment in order to
understand
uh the efficiency of a drug or
especially when it's also combined to a
protein modification
of course knowing what is the target of
the drug
you can design different kind of
experiments for
for example you can you want to see at
the replication for kinetics
so use the drug for the entire uh
experiment even within the two uh
pulsing
or you use only with the second pulse in
this case you will
bring to shortening on the
second track so on the green one and you
will see
basically that the fork speed is
actually changing between treated and
untreated cells
or you are might focus on restart
studies so you want to see whether the
fork
might will restart your bonsai treatment
or will still stall
so you can use the drug with the first
pass
or in between the two pulses as used for
example
classically with acetylcholine or
hydroxyurea
so what you will see is like restart of
replication
so in this case the green is actually
smaller than the red and this is because
the effect of the drug is actually
of our starting after uh the washout of
the drug
or the drug uh will actually uh
bring to the styling of fork and then
you will
just visualize the red truck alone
or starting of new origins so the firing
of new origins that will be in green
and then a third you will like to see
for example
the resection studies whether the drug
is bringing into the reverse fork
in this case the drug is going to be
used at the end
so and then using the exopolymerase
activity
of the replication machinery uh the
green the ide dntp
basically will be taken off from the
replication
so the signal will get shorter for the
iu
for the green and these you can see
in the picture here beside where the two
green are actually shorter
than the than the red signal itself so
this is applicable for the many uh
biomarker and many drugs for example the
parp inhibitor
to see whether there is resistance often
onsets to parp inhibitor the resection
study might be analyzed
or it can be check one to see the firing
on new origins
and so on so far for all the other
biomarkers and targets that are actually
built
of us new anti-cancer
development drug
just to give you a few example of the
possibilities
in this case we have in the first upper
panel
experiment of where fork speed has been
taken
after the cells has been treated with
neuroparibe
or cisplatin in a combination of a
protein modification that's the
from 111 in order to uh
bring to a default hr pathway
so in this case you can see the default
itself
uh so the the protein of the mutation
itself
they actually will not bring to changes
in the fork speed
but then when on top the nerve is used
you can see already the effect of
mirapari just on the fork speed itself
and then when c split in is used you can
see what is the effect of c splitting
itself
while in the lower panel you actually
see a study of the resection
and in this case it is a new compound
against p53 and you see again
the fork speed how changes and then
this has been done using the drug at the
ends
on the left panel or at the beginning on
the right panel
and then you can also find the
quantification whether it's used at the
beginning of the ends
with a strong effect on the folk speeds
only when the drug is used actually at
the ends
so of the second pulses so
this brings basically to a resection
status of the fork
itself
so all of these can be achieved by using
our um equipment and our consumables so
just starting from few cells so 10 000
cells are enough to have
a replication fork statistics
and or using 5 ml blood
so then the dna is stretched by our
fiber comp
on our engraved cover sleeve and
the digitalization of the coverslip and
visualization
of the signals is going to be done by
our fiber vision
s or fiber vision machine so these are
two automated scanners
to digitalize the cover sleep and at the
end
our fiber studio software will actually
standard dies
and help you to make all the analysis
for the replication kinetics in all
these complex
parameters that can be used in
replication kinetic studies
by this we are at the end of the second
part
of this uh webinar so where
we actually discuss about uh the
parameters that can be analyzed by our
refurbished
software what are the mechanistic aspect
of dna
replication can be quantified
uh once cells are under certain
circumstances
basically once certain kind of treatment
is done on a cell so how rca
can be combined with different kind of
compounds together over the
with the different kind of compounds and
mutation together
in order to understand and quantify
the efficiency of the drug or the
mutation itself
and then using the rca as an external
biomarker for understanding and quantify
the possible
drug efficiency and then refine
for example the treatment itself
by this we are at the very end of this
webinar i would like you
to remind that this was the third part
of
four program uh
webinar where the in the next session on
july 1st
uh the quality control advancements in
therapeutic genome editing and
manufacturing is going to be shown by my
colleague
iman mastery
by this i would like to thank you all
for your attention
and i will be happy to take your
questions thank you so much
thank you mario for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
with that let's get started our first
question um is related
to statistical significance
and the question is how much statistical
significance
is required in the rca application
hi mark and uh and everybody
so thank you for the kind question so uh
as you oh as we showed before
in our presentation rca it's
really robust methods uh so
indeed starting from 10 000 cells we
have something about an average
three thousand signals from folks on a
single
coverslips and we actually
did the analysis and we saw
that the 300 signals from fork speeds
are more than enough to actually have
statistical significance
basically with 300 signals reviewed
uh this statistical uh the std
is actually not moving anymore the
statistical deviation is actually
pretty uh fixed
okay thanks mario um
the next question is how can replication
be used to understand dna damage
well thank you this is a very crucial uh
question indeed dna replication is uh
uh impacted by the dna damage as we all
know
uh that any dna uh
damage can bring to have falling
fork or introducing some slowdown in the
fork itself
that then can be actually visualized as
an effect
of the replication kinetics as shown
putting together
the different parameters that we have so
the fork speed
to understand whether the focus is
stalling or is actually slowing down
the integration distance or
determination to see whether
dorman origins aren't fired in between
two forks
uh then you know this is a clear sign
of the dna damage going on and the
effect of the dna
damage on the replication itself
okay thanks mario the next question
that's came in
is can this application and i think
that's of molecular combing
be used for circular mitochondrial dna
well in theory yes this can be used uh
we indeed we actually have uh dna
molecules that are in the native form
and replication tracks actually show on
it
so what can be used is actually a series
of probes to identify
sequence of interests for example any
locus or any sequence of the dna
where the replication want to be
understood or we can also
by using probes indeed identify other
organelles like mitochondrial dna and
the replication going on in the
mitochondria
or using the gmc as we saw in the
previous webinar
we can also see what are the
rearrangements for example in
mitochondrial dna itself
yeah perfect thanks mario
so mario we're not showing any other
questions
at this time um do you have any final
comments for the audience mario
uh i would like to thank you all for the
attention to the presentation
and the kind questions i would like to
remind you that the replication coming
essay is a very robust and precise
method that can be used
for the dry screening and then in
still certain instances also to refine
the treatment for
patients and with these i just give you
uh
the just my best wishes to everybody and
thank you again
thanks mario for your time today and and
the work that you presented
we'd also like to thank lab roots for
facilitating today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
also like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions
if there are any other questions they
can be submitted
during the on-demand period also and
they'll be addressed via
mario and the contact information that
you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
and lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
we look forward to seeing you at part
four of our webinar series on july 1st
which is really related to the quality
coming assays
offered by genomic vision that are
important in understanding
cell line authentication during gene
editing studies
as well as bioproduction for the
production of biologics
thank you so much and have a good day